pues qué tal muy buenas tardes pues lo
cierto es que cuando a los pocos minutos
de que se confirmara que el jurado
formado por doce personas de mayoría
blanca ya había alcanzado un veredicto
en menos de 24 horas después de que se
terminara ese juicio con los argumentos
finales ya la gente centenares de
personas han venido aquí expectantes por
lo que podía pasar ya cuando el juez ha
leído que el derecho era hallado
culpable de esos tres cargos de
asesinato en segundo grado asesinato en
tercer grado y luego homicidio en
segundo grado el centro de mineápolis
frente al edificio gubernamental donde
se ha estado llevando a cabo este juicio
ha explotado de alegría muchísima gente
dice que ahora así esta sentencia
marcará un antes y un después en la
historia de eeuu y también en lo que
tiene que ver con la brutalidad policial
y racial en este país una situación una
lucha que dicen que se ha podido
conseguir gracias
al movimiento social que se ha acentuado
en estos últimos meses cuando ese vídeo
con georg floyd es tirado en el suelo y
con él el ex policía poniéndole la
rodilla en el cuello y pidiendo que no
podía respirar daban la vuelta al mundo
ahora dicen que es un paso muy
importante para la historia de eeuu
también ya hay las primeras reacciones
del gobernador de minnesota tim world ha
dicho que la lucha no ha hecho más que
comenzar y que esto supone un pequeño
paso para ir hacia adelante ángela
y se escucha desde aquí el ruido que hay
en la ciudad cómo es el ambiente sabemos
que la corte está militarizada y que se
pusieron barricadas para evitar
desórdenes
si de hecho se ha desplegado más de
4.000 miembros de la guardia nacional en
el centro de la ciudad de minneapolis
ante los posibles disturbios que podían
pasar en estas próximas horas la ciudad
está en alerta roja y hay centenares de
policías y miembros del ejército de eeuu
desplegados por está por esta zona del
centro de la ciudad sin embargo aquí hay
un ambiente de alegría mucha gente
diciendo que por fin se ha hecho
justicia en estados unidos y también
portando carteles de bulltick culpable
celebrando que por fin dicen se ha hecho
justicia con el caso de georg floyd y
derek turín el ex policía de minneapolis
ha sido hallado culpable de esos tres
cargos mire para el cierre anthony usted
nos estaba hablando de cómo este caso
podría sentar un precedente histórico en
eeuu el abuso de la fuerza policial
contra foro americano se expande cada
día hasta hoy podemos tener esperanza de
cambio gracias al movimiento black lives
at matters
si lo que decían la gente las personas
que están aquí también analistas
expertos en el tema decían que este es
esta sentencia podría marcar un
precedente en la historia de eeuu
también en el departamento de justicia
del país norteamericano porque nunca
antes se había visto este tipo de
situaciones como el movimiento social
había conseguido cambiar esta situación
básicamente porque en los los sindicatos
policiales son muy fuertes en estos
casos y prácticamente en la mayoría de
las situaciones no se llega ni a sentar
en el banquillo de los acusados a los
agentes de policial por cuestiones
relacionadas con el abuso policial sin
embargo dicen que gracias a este
movimiento social pero también a que
hubo gente que estuvo grabando con sus
teléfonos celulares lo que pasó ese
fatídico 25 de mayo del año pasado
gracias a eso dicen también se ha podido
cambiarla
el curso de la historia de eeuu y
confían en que ahora si esto suponga un
gran avance para las minorías no sólo
para las afroamericanas sino para otras
muchas otras minorías en eeuu